being trans
everyone doesn't have that look that you
can walk in the daytime
or you can go and have a regular nine to
five job
there is a lot of transgender people
doing sex work because they don't find
any job
it's a survival thing
[Music]
i immigrated to this country when i was
14.
when i get to new york city i don't have
no family here i don't have no
friends or place to go
biany garcia is a trans woman and
activist who grew up in the mexican city
of veracruz
in 2005 she paid a coyote to smuggle her
across the border
she was hoping to find a community that
would accept her sexuality
after leaving on the street for months
garcia says she was taken in by
middle-aged columbia man
who used her immigration status to
intimidate her into working for him
as an underage sex worker i do
sex work for him he always takes the
money he doesn't give me money to me
he forced me to do it because he was you
know treating me
by calling eyes called the police she
eventually escaped and
landed a job busting tables at a
manhattan restaurant
when garcia started taking hormones to
begin transitioning
she says her changing appearance caused
her to lose her job
i was looking job for three months and i
don't find anything i have to pay my
bills rents and everything
i decide to do sex work but at this time
no one was forcing me to do it or i keep
the money and
i really decide who i want to like you
know
have sex with it's a survival thing
today garcia works for the non-profit
make the road new york
eins campaign to decriminalize
prostitution
which would prevent law enforcement from
intervening in the selling of sex
between consenting adults
decriminalization bills have floundered
in new york and washington dc
and in recent months the kovi 19
pandemic has shifted attention away from
the issue
but advocates hope that the latest push
for criminal justice reform
could re-energize the movement the first
step
is for policy makers to acknowledge that
for many people
selling sex is their best option for
survival
and criminalizing that choice only makes
their lives more difficult
survival sex is just that it is survival
it's
i have no other alternative i need this
money
i'm going to do it that is a cognizant
choice
you you may not have had the best of
options on the table but you made a
choice
nat paul is a former policy chair for
national survival network
she says lawmakers and advocates
conflict consexual sex work by adults
with human trafficking
if you're making a conscious choice
it is not trafficking if there are
elements of force fraud or coercion
and you have a third party controller
who is doing the forced fraud or
coercion
that is when it becomes traffic games
yes
there is the possibility that someone is
trafficked and forced into those
situations
but the vast majority of
consensual sex work is just
work people are surviving meeting their
day-to-day needs
by selling sex the federal government
has earmarked funding to local police
departments
to crack down on trafficking but local
law enforcement agencies
often use that money to run sting
operations that lead to the arrest of
sex workers who are over the age of 18
and acting voluntarily
in december 2019 members of the
nonprofit
honor individual power and strength
organized a kickball in washington dc
to celebrate the international day to
end violence against sex workers
we're having an amazing time and
violence against sex workers
here december 17th we love you ma
come on charisse monet is a former sex
worker and advocate
supporting the trans community in the dc
area
sex work you know a lot of people
don't see it as survival work as i do
because being trans everyone doesn't
have that look that you can walk in the
daytime
or you can go and have a regular nine to
five job
so they turn that nine a.m to
nine pm sex working job where it's safe
we don't get misgendered we don't get
harassed
for coming to a workplace we don't get
questioned about what bathroom we use
and they have to change the bathroom
side
you're in your own home you deal with
one individual
so be it it's a nasty dance but it's a
dance that is done
every day
in 2019 two of monet's friends are
shanti carmen and
zoe spears who were also trans sex
workers were shot and killed in the dc
suburbs
someone never knows what actually had
transpired that evening
other than they was murdered senselessly
last year garcia was attacked with
pepper spray
on the streets of jackson heights in
queens you can get beat up
on the street and you cannot go to the
police to
to do a report that's unfair
in new york sex workers are sometimes
arrested
because of 1976 law that criminalized
loitering for the purpose of engaging in
a prostitution offense
within the sex worker community that law
is known as
working-wide trends in 2019
a handful of new york state senators
introduced legislation
that would have repealed that law but
the efforts did not succeed
i can only imagine what it is like
to be walking down the street and to be
pulled out and being harassed by police
officers
clearly we need to do something now
garcia has had several interactions with
the criminal justice system
including serving time for assault in
2010
although she says she was acting in
self-defense during a homophobic attack
she served time in rikers
they put me on a male facility um
oh my god i can i can't even i
i was um 19 years old at that time
and it was so difficult um they doesn't
give me
hormones
no women's clothes nothing like that
as a survivor of sex trafficking garcia
says the criminalization of sex work
only makes it harder for victims to
report abuses
when i was you know get forcing to do
sex
work the option of you know going to the
police passed by
my head but i was afraid of going
because
of the work that i was doing i know that
it's illegal
and they can arrest me decriminalizing
sex work is gonna help
those who are getting trafficking to not
feel afraid of going to the police
if you are not afraid of law enforcement
if you're not afraid
of going to the police because you're no
longer the target
in theory police would then be able to
focus on the abuse instead of just this
massive street suite
when garcia got off jail she joined
ukraine new york
a new coalition that helped drop the
bill to decriminalize sex work in the
state
i have many like conversations with
people that do survival sex work
i can say that most of the people that
are saying
decriminalizing sex work is not okay are
people that never
in their lives have the experience of
selling their body
to eat with
sex work i pay my mom's bills
like i pay my mother's rent i pay my
mother's
car no insurance and doing that type of
work
the stigma can be heavy on you but
for yourself you're not sitting there
saying that i give up i'm hustling i'm
we still do surviving same paperwork